suit notre rubrique rt sur le web et on
va parler de l'industrie automobile
mondiale qui est déstabilisé depuis
plusieurs mois par une pénurie de micro
conducteurs des difficultés qui se
concrétise par le ralentissement voire
l'arrêt temporaire de la production plus
de détails tout de suite avec à
pierre-alexandre faire les tic
journalistes web rc france
[Musique]
pierre-alexandre bonjour alors vous qui
avez écrit à ce sujet pouvez vous nous
en dire un peu plus sur ces matériaux
indispensables
bonjour olivier alors les semi
conducteurs sont très peu connus du
grand public mais ils sont comme on est
de le dire une matière première
indispensable à de nombreux objets
électroniques nous utilisons au
quotidien
il s'appelle ainsi car elle nous
conduisent l'électricité que dans
certaines conditions ce qui permet un
fonctionnement autonome à certains
objets qui sont par exemple utilisées
dans les capteurs des climatiseurs ou
dans les ventilateurs des ordinateurs
alors pourquoi ces composants sont si
fondamentaux se trouvent dans cette
situation de pénurie
eh bien il s'agit d'une énième
conséquences de la pandémie de covile 19
en effet nombreuses usines produisant
les semi-conducteurs se situent en asie
du sud-est et sont à l'arrêt en raison
de la propagation du variant de l'alta
cette situation touche particulièrement
le secteur automobile y compris en
france
oui en effet cette semaine c'était
gentil ça a été contraint de fermer
partiellement son usine historique de
sochaux et l' usine de rennes dans le
nord à valenciennes c'est toyota qui a
également dû suspendre pour deux
semaines sa production quelle est la
réaction des salariés face à cette
baisse d'activité fort c'est finalement
et bien à valenciennes par exemple
environ 4500 personnes sont mises en
activité partielle avec 84 % de leur
salaire net mais les salariés ne
toucheront plus leurs primes et les
syndicats craignent pour le statut des
intérimaires sur le site de psa noren
les représentants syndicaux ont déclaré
attendre beaucoup d'un programme
d'investissements de 20 milliards
d'euros visant à accélérer la route la
relocalisation de la production de semi
conducteurs en france afin je cite que
notre industrie ne soit plus dépendantes
des productions en provenance de taiwan
alors pierre alexandre il s'agit donc
d'un problème
mondiale finalement qui dépasse les
frontières de l'hexagone
oui tout à fait le géant américain ford
a estimé que la pénurie pour entraîner
une baisse de sa production d'un million
de véhicules par rapport à ce qui a été
prévu en 2021 et de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique audi a mis au chômage
partiel dix mille salariés allemands
tandis que porsche a trouvé une solution
originale en livrant certains de ses
véhicules sans semi conducteurs qui
seront installés par la suite bon reste
à savoir quand car cette pénurie n'est
pas prête de s'arrêter dès plus
optimiste évoquant une possible
amélioration de la situation me 2022
merci beaucoup bien alexandre faire les
tic pour toutes ces précisions je le
rappelle on peut vous lire sur notre
site rt france pointé ray vous retrouvez
également toute toute l'actualité et
c'est la fin